Amy Schumer makes a lasting impression  on newlyweds checks out the comedian  never shied away from creating hilarious  moments here's to nothing getting in the  way of our adventure on Thursday the  snatch star pranked a bride and groom as  they posed for wedding pictures in  London  Jasmine Pereira and John Bates had just  exchanged vows at the Mayfair library  moments before Amy creeped up behind  them and a photo bomb to their pick  we've been emotional about it all day  the 36 year old funny gal was on her way  to meet designer pal Stella McCartney  but stayed a little longer allowing the  newlyweds to get some snaps near her  private car in 2016 Schumer declared she  would no longer take photos with people  after a run-in with an aggressive fan  you don't do anything fun anymore  she later clarified in an Instagram post  that she would still take pictures with  nice people if the time was right  it seems Jasmine and John passed  Schumer's test  you